Joshua I was watching the NBA Finals on
television last night and saw an ad that
I'm sure a lot of people saw a long one
with jay-z and it made me curious
maybe that's what Samsung wants for you
to be curious about its own brand sure I
mean Samsung is trying to offer
something with its phones that no one
else has and by having an exclusive
offer to let people listen to jay-z's
album a couple days early that's that's
something that Apple or other flavors of
Android aren't gonna be able to offer
you know we had Roger McNamee the
well-known tech investor at our next big
thing summit saying that if it's Apple
or Samsung really just knowing that
people are buying these phones means
that maybe we should move to the
software side more focus on that does
jay-z do a lot to actually make the
phone experience that much better well I
think what what jay-z offers is a it's a
service that you can't get somewhere
else people use their phones to listen
to music you don't necessarily need
innovative software to give something
they want it's just it's some content
that you're not going to find elsewhere
right comparing say what they're doing
to Apple and Google with the Apple and
Google music streaming services what
would you say to that I know in a lot of
ways it's the same if Apple can come up
with a compelling music service that
offers something that say Pandora
doesn't then there's an incentive to get
an Apple phone as opposed to another
phone where you might just run the
Pandora app same with Google if their
music service offers something better
than the competition then you're going
to want a Google phone